it's kind of how I see the world I see
the the mainstream media as a
cartoonification of reality and a lot of
I find a lot of my work is just trying
to complicate it you can just kill it by
complicating it because that's the way
the world is and so I did I did think
it's in in the last episode when we when
we released the project the the goal was
to use influential people just to get
the maximum amount of information out
there
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast uh I have the distinct pleasure
of sitting this morning while it's this
morning for me it's this evening for
Mike but with one of my favorite people
Mike Naina Mike Naina is a little bit
hard to encapsulate I know him as a
documentary filmmaker that's the
capacity in which I met him I'm not sure
that's exactly the right description
although it's accurate it just seems to
me now somewhat incomplete Mike Welcome
To Dark Horse and how would you describe
your role in the universe
well it's a it's a big opening question
let's just say filmmaker it's nice and
neat and then we can complicate it from
there
um yeah I'm a filmmaker okay that's what
I like doing what I like doing with my
time and I call myself when I'm in rooms
with dignified people
yeah but the problem with it is it's a
little bit like
calling a builder a
wood shortener
right you do a lot of wood shortening to
make a building but the building is kind
of the objective
um
and the reason that I'm a little bit
hesitant to just say a filmmaker is that
your
films are
unusual to say the least and maybe maybe
that's just simply the nature of
filmmaker maybe all filmmakers uh who
are not just phoning it in or trying to
do something dramatic with their art but
anyway maybe because I know you and I
also know the subjects of at least a
couple of your films I'm able to see how
thoughtfully you
characterize your subject matter and it
raises all kinds of questions in my mind
about what it is that you are actually
seeking to accomplish whether it's even
doable
but anyway maybe maybe filmmaker is
exactly the right description and I'm
not giving the category enough credit
but in any case I am interested you're
here on the occasion of the release of
your latest series The reformers which
is a four-part documentary on the
um
why am I blanking on the monitor or even
studies Affair or your circle square
it's got a few different names depending
on the circle squared Infamous grievance
studies Affair The Grieving studies
affair
um which is
uh an interesting episode in academic
history at least it's one in which I
play a sort of very distant uh auxiliary
role
um
and we met as you were filming what
ultimately went on to be the reformers
and you did a sort of side project on
the Evergreen meltdown which I would and
I would encourage and I have frequently
encouraged people to look at because I
think it does
an excellent job of in encapsulating
what took place at Evergreen which I
thought frankly was impossible I did not
think it would be possible to present it
in a way that the public would actually
understand what it was like I thought
they would always see a caricature and
anyway you did a great job uh with uh
you know Benjamin Boyce has done a much
more exhaustive dive it's a very
different
um
Corpus of work he of course was a
graduate of Evergreen so he was on the
ground and has a very different
perspective but anyway it's a meticulous
archival work which I kind of Lent into
to do my thing I guess
um he was the one aggregating all the
footage and
um meticulously submitting Freedom of
Information requests and he was even
behind the camera on a few of the things
so I think he was working for Evergreen
AV and so
um he was very I guess we collaborated
on that that series you could say
yeah
um
it is yes he did an exhaustive you might
even say an obsessive job of unearthing
material which I think
the world has to be grateful for because
it is
in many ways a study of a kind of
dysfunction that has now become so
widespread that
um
exploring how it actually unfolds on the
ground is is important work it's an
interesting case study I guess I don't
want to hop on too much because our
audiences have seen so much of Evergreen
but uh Evergreen is the case study it's
kind of like a a small version of
um what happens when these ideas reach
critical mass and don't really have much
of much of a pushback and what happened
there was was was fascinating and anyone
who's who looks through all the footage
and speaks to people about what went on
the ground there it was kind of a modern
day witch burning event or something
like that and it it draws you in and so
you've got yourself talking about it for
for many years I mean you're part of it
so everyone asks you about it and you've
got me who got drawn into it and
obsessively focused on it you've got uh
Benjamin Boyce who obsessively focused
on it you've got uh Pamela
peresky who helped Jonathan height
untangle it in um in the coddling of the
American mind
um you've got Tim Urban who recently
released his book and there's this
there's a whole chapter on Evergreen and
he mentions the series on it and so
there's and there's several several
people have reached out to me and done
uh someone did a PhD thesis on it uh
several people have looked in and
actually started it in a kind of
sociological way and so there's
something about what took place there
that that draws you in and um yeah if
you haven't seen the series or Benjamin
series just go check it out I think it's
worthwhile yeah it does draw you in
which is it has just done to us once
again which as you point out is not the
right place for us to focus
um but I will say it is cousin to your
work with the reformers your project
um in an important way because
the Evergreen meltdown
was the product of the kind of
scholarship that the circle squared
folks were trying to unmask with their
work
right so they're like two stages of the
same process and in some ways by
starting with the Meltdown or releasing
the Meltdown work first you are
revealing where it goes and then it
actually I think makes a wonderful
argument for
what the reformers Peter pagosian James
Lindsay and Helen pluck Rose I take it
they are the reformers to whom you refer
in the title of your your doc
um but it explains why they would have
gone to the extraordinary lengths that
they did to
um to reveal the full depth of insanity
that had gotten loose in the academy and
taken hold in all of these phony Fields
so anyway I do see them as great uh
as complementary pieces of the same
puzzle
this episode is sponsored by house of
macadamias you can't eat trees but tree
nuts are delicious and nutritious they
are generally high in fat and low in
carbohydrates and contrary to what
various food pyramids and government
agencies may have led you to believe
high fat low carb foods are both
satisfying and good for you but each
species of nut is different and for many
of us macadamias are the best nut there
is macadamia nuts take a very long time
to grow however and because they are
both rare and highly sought after they
have the dubious distinction of being
the world's most expensive nut between
the taste and the health benefits though
they're worth it they have even fewer
carbohydrates than most other nuts for
instance half of what cashews and
pistachios have and two-thirds of what
almonds have which makes them the
perfect snack for breaking a daily fast
and controlling blood glucose they're
also uniquely rich in omega-7s including
especially palmettoic acid and
unsaturated fat that has been linked to
Natural collagen production fat loss and
heart health and House of macadamias is
intent on making this amazing food
accessible to everyone they have
partnered with more than 90 farmers in
Africa and now make one-of-a-kind vegan
keto and paleo snacks these include
their dark chocolate dipped macadamias
and a delicious assortment of bars made
with 45 macadamia nuts in flavors
including salted caramel chocolate
coconut but our favorite is their simple
salted macadamias made with namibian sea
salt they're amazing we love them and we
think you will too
House of macadamias also makes a
delicious macadamia nut oil which is 100
cold-pressed rich in monounsaturated
fatty acids and has a higher smoke point
than Olive Oil so it's well suited to
high heat cooking and baking and now
they make delicious macadamia nut
Butters our house of academia's Highly
recommends House of macadamias for all
your macadamic needs for a limited time
House of macadamias is offering
listeners a free box of their best
seller namibian sea salted macadamia
nuts worth 35 bucks with your purchase
at houseofmacademias.com Darkhorse plus
20 off your whole order with the code
Darkhorse once again that's
houseofmacademias.com use the code
Darkhorse for 20 off every order you
won't be sorry
[Music]
but let me ask you I've looked at the
reformers I am
um
simultaneously
I don't want to overstate it but I'm
delighted by it and I'm terrified by it
there's something about
let's take Alan Circle right the circle
squared hoax is
um a play on the earlier chapter in
academic history when physicist Alan
Sokol
um perpetrated a famous hoax on uh a
post-modern journal he effectively you
correct me if I've got it wrong but he
submitted a paper that when you
translated from the academic jargon
effectively said we used to believe in
reality but now we know better it was
accepted and published and then he
revealed his hoax in a second Journal
and the point was if the peer review
process can't spot and obviously nutty
claim like this
then what's it good for what is it
feeding us if it doesn't have a
sufficiently decent filter to spot
obvious garbage
and
the contrast
sorry about that
the contrast that I would draw is that
in Alan sokol's case the only thing I
know about Alan Circle
is
what he chose to present of himself
and so there's a way in which the
so-called hoax
has taken on a degree of respectability
a powerful degree of respectability
because of
I wish it didn't have to be this way but
the careful curation of the presentation
of Sokol and his meaning and intent and
what you do in the reformers that's
interesting it's an interesting take
yeah yeah because it's really hard to
um
James and I call him the intellectual
Country Club to get them to listen to
anything and there is a lot of kind of
meticulous I would say pedantic work
that needs to be done in order to get
their ear and so
um yeah I I find it interesting that you
would look at it like that because I
haven't really looked at it like that
before
well even if I don't have Circle right
and I'm not convinced that I don't
um what you do in the reformers is you
effectively follow
Lindsay and pluck Rose
through
the development you you capture them
actually conceptualizing how they will
perpetrate their hoax
um you follow them through the trials
and tribulations of their papers as they
work their way through peer review
and
you know let's just say I can't be
objective about it because I know and
like all three people and I know and
like you as a filmmaker and so that
makes it a really difficult exercise to
see what's just simply on the screen and
separate it from my personal feelings
but I do worry
that you present such a I think complete
and accurate picture of the people
involved that it may be hard for those I
mean in some ways we are where we are
because we ignored Alan Sokol
right Alan Circle revealed the problem
and a generation later things are way
worse
and so now this is the sort of a next
phase of
the uh trying to Ring the Alarm Bell and
here you have these people and the
question is can the public
is the public mature enough to accept a
warts and all presentation of these
folks you call reformers presented as
you do well I find it very very
interesting that you look at it that way
because
um Let me let me let me talk about the
the intent here because
um
I have a problem with filmmaking as
activism and so for me to present them
in in any different way other than what
I genuinely saw of them would be a form
of activism because it's the the film is
designed to an end does that make sense
yeah and so and so I just don't want to
make films like that and I I think on
some level it's it's kind of
too much of that takes place and I don't
even know if it's effective anymore it's
just it's just these just a complete dis
complete and utter discourse Engineering
in a battle with with the content that's
being thrown back and forth at uh you
know different targets and things like
that so it's kind of very constructed
environment in which we find ourselves
but
I resolved and I even said this to the
guys at the time while I was making it
because I want people to know what I'm
doing I don't want to kind of
um reveal too much of them without
without them being okay with that and
what I did what I did at the time was
was I'm happy to get involved in the
project itself
and I'm happy to to create some activism
which you see in um in part I think it's
part four which which I get involved in
the presentation of the the media
release and and kind of
present them in such a way that the the
intellectual Country Club will be
interested in what they have to have and
actually just look at the information
but after that I said that I'm not I'm
not a PR guy after that point I'm just
going to show what what I saw and that's
all I wanted to do so I guess it's in
some sense it's a faith that revealing
all or revealing the truth as I saw it
will will do something or or even like
or even perhaps
I don't even care that much I don't
think I care about the activism
side of it
um
yeah you're making me grapple with now
yeah I mean it's interesting to me that
you hear activism uh as a relevant part
of what I was saying it's really not
um or at least I don't know it to be I
think you are involved now that I hear
you talk you are involved
in a Gamble and oddly I think I am
involved in the very same gamble in a
very different way right your gamble if
I you tell me if I've got it wrong
is
that complete authenticity
will move us in the right direction
and
I am pretty sure that authenticity
is the reason that
Heather and I
survived in some sense what did happen
and everything that the ability
to respond to it with no fear that
exposing the whole picture of what we
believed wasn't going to reveal
something some you know dire flaw in our
characters
that that actually attracted people
because as I've said elsewhere we live
in an era
so drenched in that people have
become
rightly cynical
and when they detect that something does
not require that cynicism cynicism
many of them respond positively to it so
I am I right that your your presentation
I think you're right you're right in
some sense but I still detect activism
there because it's it's it's it's almost
it's it's that I don't really care it's
it's that I I want to live in an
authentic world and so I proceed that
way
and it's it's not to an end do you know
what I mean I think that it's I I hope
maybe but I but I don't actually know
that do you know what I mean the way you
you set that up was
you're involved in a gamble that your
authenticity will change the world and
so on and so forth I don't know I don't
know that far I can't abstract that far
or I don't have actually any
understanding of what my actions will do
past a certain point but
I
I do want to live in a world where we
can where we can reveal
um and explore characters in a real way
and
and tell I guess tell the truth in some
way and and I guess I set out at the
start of this project that way as well
because I I came into it without it
without a without a solid understanding
of the huge huge activists academic
Canon that I was stepping stepping up
towards and I thought well what do I do
in the face of that and one you do a
shitload of reading and you try to
understand it as best you can and I
think I've come out the other end with
the ability to say something about it
but at the time while I was filming I I
had to find a way to tell the story that
wasn't from some kind of God's eye view
where I knew what it was where I knew
the right questions to ask or I knew
what it was exactly that I was I was
attacking and so that the answer to that
to me was all right I'm gonna go have
this experience
and I'm gonna share it and I'm gonna
share my learnings along the way
um and so anything anything other than
that with
a how do you how do you say an end game
in it ends kind of point that I'm
working towards to me it strikes me as
some some kind of activism I just it's
well I hope I don't drive the audience
Crazy by pursuing this but I do think my
guess the professor in me thinks if we
keep digging here we're gonna find
something interesting yeah okay you keep
hearing activism I don't think that's
what I'm saying I think what I'm saying
let's put it this way activism I hear
you talk about activism and I hear you
talk about an end point with which you
do not resonate I don't think I'm
talking about an end point I think I'm
talking about a net change
and that the what I see you doing again
you tell me if I've got it wrong but
what I see you doing is engaged in an
unusual kind of filmmaking that and
maybe I'm working from what I think I
know about your character that you
believe
advances the ball that we are better off
for your film existing than not existing
and that means that the content of your
film which is
I would say radically open about your
subjects
is net positive
um well I would say it's net positive
because otherwise why would I do it but
it a a big part of it is it's it's kind
of my DNA it's just how I say that I
can't I don't think I can see the world
in another way and if I if I do
um if I was to create something that was
more traditional or another way I it
would feel it would feel like
manipulation I would feel like I'm
manipulating the audience and so what I
guess I'm trying to do is to share my
experiences and and my my genuine
perspective and my fondness for the
humans that are involved in this and
that that the end there is filmmaking
the end there is is to have a
presentation that that people can enjoy
and
um it just so happens to be in this
extremely politically uh what would you
call kind of
volatile uh landscape but it's the thing
that interested me and then it's how I
saw it okay um but but I did I did have
a goal I did I did have an activist goal
through uh throughout and I show it in
the film and so it might not make sense
in for the people who haven't seen it
but um that that's another layer that's
that's in it well I want to know the
thing that's going on here is you're
you're asking me to get very analytical
about something that feels natural and
so it might it might sound like
gibberish to a lot of people and maybe
you're even maybe you're even better
positioned to be to be your your
perspective might even be better than
the thing that's coming out of me right
now because
um when you try and look at yourself
it's like Alice in Wonderland it's
you're chasing your tail and it's very
difficult well you know I do this is
this is part of my the weird aspect of
my character as an evolutionary
biologist and also an absolute addict
when it comes to Nature especially
watching animals right so I am both
involved in trying to understand the
nature of those creatures and why they
would do anything that they would do
that is expensive
also
just freaking love watching monkeys and
so the point is to me it's very natural
to take an analytical approach to what
you did as a a passionate contribution
to the world those things are not
inconsistent they're they're two sides
of the same coin
but let me ask you oh go ahead and if
you had a response to that no no
just backing up the the the
realization earlier which was it's very
it's very hard to when you're making a
piece of art which I think that was
um which I think it is it's it's very
hard to describe why you do it you just
you just do it
and I always I always hated the
write-ups next to
um paintings you know the paintings and
then you've got the the write-ups next
to us what is this and you know that
that you have to fill out a form in
order to get your painting into a an art
gallery and you're just going to say
some you're you're almost plug
in like something into the political uh
landscape so then you can actually get
seen by people but you you I often I
often find myself reading the
descriptions or even the descriptions
the artist gives them like what are you
talking about that's
I have that same Instinct and and you
know I'm not an artist in any realm I
don't think but
um but I do resonate with the idea that
almost inherently in fact I can only
think of a couple of exceptions almost
inherently art in order to be genuine
has to be motivated by something other
than analytical purpose
right Escher would be the case that I
might argue actually blurs that
distinction where
create a staircase that cannot exist
yeah at any single point is visually
compelling like that's something
he's like trying to he's yeah yeah that
is interesting because the the Endeavors
paradoxical and so the thing that comes
out of it is paradoxical as well that's
interesting but I always I actually
worked with James and Helen on cynical
theories which I see as an accompaniment
to it because that that they wrote a
book that that that
um tracked the intellectual lineage of
the things that they were attacking in
the in the hoax
um in the hoax project and they did a
lot of analytical work there which which
I became very interested in I was you
know maybe research assistant or
something I don't really know how to
describe what I did there but I was
involved in it and I always saw I always
felt felt like that gave me leeway to do
something
um a little more weird I guess or a
little a little more artistic a little
less analytical and maybe that
yeah I think I think they work well
together those the the book and the film
um oh yeah yeah wonderful companions for
each other because they really do uh one
is the fiercely analytical approach and
the other
um I mean it really leaves a lot to the
viewer
you have created a window a literal
almost literal window into a period of
history that explains an event right and
um
oh I guess the question is well what
what will the audience think
um but I really really like that because
that's that's kind of how I thought
about it and also also I walk around
that window like I'm messing with the
fourth wall in it and so I'm trying to
I'm uh I'm walking around that window
and turning it around and yeah I really
like it yeah I really like that I mean
there's one scene in it that is um
there's a
there's a thing that James Lindsay has
been taken to merciless task over which
is his
I don't know experimentation in his own
backyard with some absolutely long sword
that he's like anime sides yeah it's
like an anime sized sword and he's doing
some uh
some combination of Tai Chi I don't know
he's doing something it's not it's it's
a marshall I forgot the name of it but
it's it's a martial art that he really
likes and it's actually it's quite
graceful it's like I call it sword
dancing that that we made us we made a
song to go underneath it and we called
that sword dancing right it's sword
dancing and my feeling is
this is
Beyond critique
right the fact that James gets something
out of this
there is literally nothing that you can
say that calls it into question in any
regard until
it becomes public and it is so easily
mocked right yeah and so when can I can
I can I come just before you go in
there's an interesting thing that took
place around this someone sent me
um
there's a kind of cottage industry on
on critiquing James Lindsay and so
there's a lot of people who are who are
gaining a lot of notoriety just by
constantly critiquing him obsessively so
and uh someone sent me
um that a a post or a series of posts
from one of these guys who had
um
paid to see the film and then ripped
sections of it and then we're sharing it
to mock James and the interesting thing
I found was he was mocking James for
this particular event we won't we won't
go into it
um I mean you can if you want but we
won't go into what happens this sword
dancing event in the film and I really
liked a lot of people came in into his
defense it's like you're missing
something if you don't find this
endearing you're some kind of idiot and
so it's right lots and lots of people
came into to bet uh to to defend him and
I really I really enjoyed that I really
I thought about blocking the guy because
he was you know quite literally ripping
the film and then sharing it and I want
it to be behind paywalls for uh for my
own reasons but then I just left it open
I was like yeah I don't know this guy
can't
his trick isn't working here it's it
yeah well that's that's beautiful
actually and it mirrors a bunch of
experiences that I've had and not known
what to think about them
but I guess let's put it this way if the
environment in which the public comes to
understand what it thinks about stuff
was truly indifferent right if there was
not a ghost in the machine playing games
with trying to cultivate certain
perceptions
then I think there is something actually
wonderful about
exactly the scenario you described right
where something that is valid
easily mocked
is then presented in public and people
do not Retreat because it's easily
mocked they actually stand up and say no
this is unfair right you're being unfair
that's a great process right where we
come to correct our emergent
understanding of something in public
and I've seen it happen because the
whole game the whole game is the cartoon
cartoonify someone and so Jane James
makes it very easy to cartoonify him
um him on social media because he's
playing some cartoon it's not it's not
the James I know and so then if you show
vulnerability
perhaps it's vulnerable human
vulnerability it's it's all of a sudden
there's this big giant famous monster
that's ushering in or neo-fascism or
whatever is is a human being and it's
really it's then it's quite difficult to
um differentiate differentiate the the
person you're seeing on the screen from
sorry to not differentiate the people
we've personally seen from the screen
from the cartoon that's being created
well you know it's funny I do want to
get back to
the three primaries in your film and
they're radically different
personalities and approaches and how the
film reveals those distinctions and what
those distinctions actually mean
but
I want to cover two things first
one
as somebody who has been demonized and
falsely portrayed and cartoonified
almost endlessly for the last six years
I resonate with the idea that one
approach is to try and put enough pieces
of what you actually are
in public that it becomes almost
impossible to portray you as anything
other than you actually are in other
words if you're comfortable with the
warts and all presentation of yourself
one way to immunize yourself from some
of it is to be more complete than you
would like to be right
and I have noticed that the next phase
in that arms race
is a concerted effort to get people to
feel icky for giving you a chance
right in other words there's an army of
sock puppets that erupts in the replies
to anything I do
and its purpose is to create the
impression that I have been discredited
and that anybody who doesn't see through
the obvious that I am putting
into the world is themselves revealing
their own mental deficiency right this
is nonsense but the point is if you
didn't know who I was and you
encountered that you might think oh God
I don't see through him maybe that means
I'm being a fool
and the point is that's such an annoying
thing to have to wrestle with that I'm
sure large numbers of people walk away
at that moment it's not that they accept
the portrayal it's the thing except that
they do not know what to think and they
don't want to take the risk of being
revealed as foolish
yeah so anyway that
um there is an arms race but I do think
the
unusually complete and maybe
unfortunately complete picture that some
of us put into the world is a defense
against being caricatured and that might
be very much a description of what James
is doing that that's that's that's
interesting because the people with
audiences who have traveled with them a
long time
tend to have a force field around them
there's there is an attempt often aided
by the the mainstream media to
cartoonify someone and then critique
them into the ground with cynical
critiques and gather the warts and not
leave the all and just gather the warts
and present them and create this this
Effigy that people will then go ahead
and burn this digital Effigy
um
and the the the kind of how do you how
would you say the inoculation is as you
put it is having an audience that has
been with you through some and so
um who will stand up for you in in these
times
um when people come after you it is it
is it's like an arms race of building
identities and influence and then taking
those identities down and both both of
them employ a kind of cartoonifying or
or you know Persona building
um
yeah I I find I find this this line of
uh conversation very very interesting
because I think it's the main
theme in the film but from a from a from
a from
I didn't know I was doing it with the
characters that much I just kind of did
it but it's kind of how I see the world
I see the the mainstream media as a
cartoonification of reality and a lot of
I find a lot of my work is just trying
to complicate it and just kill it by
complicating it
um because that's the way the world is
and so I did I did think it's in in the
last episode when we when we released
the project the the goal was to use
influential people just to get the
maximum amount of information out there
about the project and what was happening
and what we found and so on and so forth
and I thought that that kind of
flash flood of information would make it
very hard to construct the project into
something that was easily taken down and
so I I think that there's this kind of
there's this kind of mass communication
strategy that can take place in these
things and I did I often think about how
individuals are cartoonified on the
internet and how I I I don't see them as
cartoons and so it's hard for me to to
to string someone up yeah who's who's
been shamed or something like that
because I just don't see them as the
Effigy that's getting burnt but um yeah
it is I like it when people watch my
films and then deliver something back to
me that might be going on in them
well I you know I mean obviously this is
a fascinating topic to me for reasons
that are very personal
um but
the
I have had the experience many many
times especially over the last six years
of encountering somebody who
I had what I thought was a pretty
complete picture
from their Public Presentation
and then I encounter them in personal
space
and they are very different than I had
imagined very different and I then
watched this happen to people with me
right people who have gotten some
impression and then we meet
interpersonally and it
in some cases rocks their world because
it reveals how false an impression can
be if you're standing in the wrong spot
and so you know again I don't want to
torture you as an artist I don't want to
torture you by trying to stick the label
next to the piece that you've put on the
wall of the gallery
but I am fascinated by what it is and
how it works and one thing I see you
doing you are you make no bones about
the fact in your film or anywhere else
that you like the subjects that you are
documenting
and that means that you document their
warts
out of affection and not out of mouth
yeah they're not Wards to me they're
they're endearing endearing
vulnerabilities maybe I I I like that I
like that more if I was if I was in the
presence of a perfect person I don't
think I'd like them no you'd hate them
but but I guess my point is look I'm not
supposed to be just out of your boring
but anyway go on most people are not in
a position
to meet James Lindsay
and the presentation that he gives
online makes many of us uncomfortable I
think right there's stuff there
that I just wish he wouldn't do yeah and
what you are doing is in some sense
providing a friend level view of the
human being
that is a wonderful corrective for the
um
the aggressive yeah for the monster
um and so anyway again I do think that
that's kind of a a um a Gamble
but
I don't also I also don't think anyone
is good at presenting themselves on the
internet I think that there is some I
don't think anyone is good at presenting
themselves full stop that's where you
get these body dysmorphia things it's
you don't you really don't know how you
look to the outside world and you know
most of you in Psychology which I find
very interesting is to try and try and
figure out what parts of yourself you
don't see so you can come into into
alignment with them
um but we don't we won't go too far down
that mad rabbit hole but um I think that
something's taking place on the internet
where we're forced to consciously
construct a Persona and I think I think
it's driving people mad I think that a
lot of a lot of people think about think
about an identity in a town with no
with no where internet hasn't hasn't
come into play you're in a small rural
town where I am now actually you're in
Germany in a farming Town your identity
is is built in concert with the people
around you and it's usually something
that you're doing identity is done not
presented and so you know you might you
may wear some weird clothes or you play
with it especially when you're a
teenager but that's kind of like a a an
awkward phase you go through where
you're trying to construct what the
world sees of you most people just kind
of oh I think healthy people
um well-rounded people just just do
their identity into adulthood and now
we're forced to construct your persona
digitally and it's it's very it's also
very hard to see people receive your
persona in a way that you don't want
them to to to receive it as well and so
there's a lot of pathologies around
wanting to control the way that people
see you
um and and
other people are trying to control the
way people see you for their own
purposes and so does this this kind of
mad
um mad Persona building and destroying
process that's taking place and it's
also making people build their morality
you know it's someone who's too online
there's a kind of a digital super ego
that that people are around trying to
construct and I think that these
grievance studies people are trying to
create this this
um this this construct in order to
literally
um so yeah I guess literally in a way
program the personalities of the world
to to their activist ends and so there
there is this kind of construction of a
these these super egos are going to war
on the internet trying to build the
people on the outside and if you're too
online you are going to be heading to
into all kinds of pathologies when
you're when you're when you're playing
with that and I think that's that's
something it's very interesting it's
very interesting being
here in um in Germany where I know the
language enough to get by but I don't
know it very well so I get to avoid all
the and just interact with
people and interact with I really love
love being in a place like this because
we don't abstract too far into
nothingness we're just there together
and being and these people these people
don't really mess with the internet the
next generation is for sure but
um they're all farmers and doers and
well-rounded kind people and I really I
really really like it here
all right that was around no that was
the Nugget that was the thing that I was
torturing you to get you to say because
it's it's
incredibly deep and important and
actually dovetails was something that
Heather frequently talks about it's not
only
the artifice that arises out of the
online presentation and one's ability to
curate it in a way that is unnatural
but it is also
the durability of past versions of it
right in other words
you are supposed to go through that
awkward phase as a teenager where you
get to figure out who you are and you're
not supposed to be dogged for the rest
of your life by a snapshot from it right
that is not something you're supposed to
be permanently stuck with is something
that is supposed to decay in the
memories of those who knew you at the
time and becomes unimportant and
so I do think there is a kind of
insanity that arises out of the ability
to curate your own image and actually be
able to curate other people see there's
That Awkward Moment the teenager has
that disappears but think about someone
that doesn't like you they're probably
doing this mentally they're aggregating
all your slip UPS
um and now that now they can do it in a
in a more I think it's it's digital but
it's still physical they do it in a
physical way they're aggregating all of
your slip ups and then and then
casting their version of you out there
often in some kind of political
assassination uh attack even not even
slip-ups
um
re-reframes ticks yeah ways that you
phrase things words that you use too
frequently right all of these things are
vulnerabilities because and here here's
one of the punch lines from my
perspective I think the insanity that
you are diagnosing
actually goes back
to the invention of the
the proper mirror
before there were before there was flat
glass and a silver coating that made an
accurate mirror there were polished
pieces of metal that gave you an
impression of how you might look but it
wasn't highly reliable because they
weren't really that flat
um the closer you get to being able to
regard yourself as someone else sees you
the greater the temptation to try to
alter what they see right there's a
positive feedback that kicks in if your
only understanding of how you looked to
other people was how they reacted to you
it would cause you you know if you
did something one day and it caused
people not to interact with you very
well or not to look you in the eye or
whatever you might not know why you
didn't feel so great about what you did
that day but you would over time adjust
your presentation so that it resulted in
people interacting with you in the way
that was best right
so you might in fact end up accidentally
you know you ever meet somebody and
they're not
classically attractive but they are
undeniably attractive the way they carry
themselves is yeah and you just think I
like this person I like to be around
this person right
um
that that genuineness would Encompass a
much wider range of phenotypes than this
artificial situation I mean it's become
hyper artificial in the modern world but
the ability to know what you look like
the ability to modify what you look like
the ability to
um surgically alter what you look like
the ability to cultivate that which you
present online and now the ability to
use uh filters and other kinds of tech
including artificial intelligence to
present something that's Predator
naturally one way or the other these
things are definitely driving us crazy
yeah yeah and we'd be better off without
him and I I do believe you based on what
you just said say something uh that I so
please I'm friends with um
two crazy South African boys who decided
to make social media platforms and uh we
we were trying to make we were
collaborating on this for quite a while
we're trying to make social media
platforms that were healthy and so there
was one there was one social media
platform where it's a bit hard it's a
bit obscure and hard to hard to just
describe exactly what it was but
it was
a social media platform where you're the
people around you actually ended up
building your
um profile
so people would write letters about
someone and then it would be an
aggregation of these letters and then
you could go there and get get a view of
how some whose house who someone was but
from scene from the outside
and I mean it sounds kind of basic and
weird and you know it's very very
difficult to scale something like that
up because it doesn't have all the brain
stem stuff but we saw some very very
interesting psychological things happen
from that I went around and shot
um interviews with people who were using
this and I was able to make every one of
them cry just with one single question
one question you would find one letter
that said something and you would ask
them about it and they would seriously
cry and they would
would be so fascinated about the way
that the world viewed them that you know
if you look behind the scenes you could
see that everyone was looking at their
own uh profile and and you know
rereading their own letters and things
like that and the other thing is the the
the process of writing about someone
else was very therapeutic for people
because it was almost like gratitude for
having these people in your in their
lives and so I found that that very very
interesting
um
as I said you know you can't scale those
sorts of things up it's not sugar and
fat but
um
it it taught me a lot about the you know
the psychology the psychological
interface that we have with our current
social media platforms and it's
something I think it's something in that
that cultivation and presentation of a
constructed Persona and actually like
analytically doing that rather than it
naturally happening is um is is very
very unhealthy
um yeah this is fascinating and by the
way that doesn't sound at all strange to
me it's not surprising to me that this
hasn't taken over social media space but
um
there is something
your social group
in an in a you know 300 years ago
your social group has leeway
to reflect back at you things that you
do need to know about yourself out of
genuine concern for you and it may do
this by mocking you right your friends
may have a good laugh about something
about that you do that you don't realize
is a thing and that good laugh may be
kind of painful and you may laugh along
with them or you may not but the point
is if if you have a group in which
everybody agrees hey we like you or you
wouldn't be here yeah right so if we're
mocking you about this thing it's not
because we've changed our mind about you
right it's part of it it's it's like a
mirror it's like an intelligent mirror
that doesn't cause you to obsess on
something that's actually not important
because you can't figure out what it is
but it's actually you know if done by
the more decent your friend group the
better job they will do at letting you
know what you need to know and
insulating you from things that are
probably not in your interest to know
and
um we have lost touch with this in part
because
you know the the modern internet is a
you have too much power to curate how
you present in the world B you have way
more antagonists than is normal for Life
unless you're not doing anything
interesting but if you're doing
something interesting you just
automatically have people trying to tear
you down looking for vulnerabilities
pretending you know frankly pretending
that there are more people than they
actually are showing up with Anonymous
accounts trying to create a chorus where
there's one person you know trying to
exploit something
all of these things are
uh routes to
a kind of insanity
and
to bring it back to your
your art
it is a kind of antidote to this because
it is undeniably I mean you know Peter
bagosian
talking to you his friend about the
status of his project while lying in his
bed
you know under the covers like you
didn't stage it right that's real
whatever that is that is real a nice
paint it's it's Peyton one of the most
open humans on the planet yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah he is uh I mean it's strange I
I was watching it and I thought there's
a part of me that wants to apply the
term guileless to Peter pagosian it's
not the right term right he is he is
like
a Noble
impish he's like you know what he is
he's like
um
the coyote
character or Raven character from Native
American Myth you know the sort of
mischievous
um
creature that reveals your foibles that
kind of thing yeah yeah
the the it's the joke The Joker the the
it's the same thing right yeah the
trickster yeah
he does he does occupied an interesting
mental space
I get so much joy I get so much joy for
him and
um he often he often slips up and says
something that you know my my kind of
millennial training goes oh you should
have said that but right once he once he
can get over that he gets a lot of
enemies because of that that uh he that
kind of 90s bronus he's got going but um
um if you can get past that is an
endless well of of joy and peat moments
there's all these like really funny Pete
moments that I can just
James and I laugh about it all the time
we just we just talk about Pete moments
and giggle our asses off it's really
funny yeah well I mean it does sort of
reflect that uh more ancient style of
friend group that I'm talking about
where you know you recognize Pete is uh
Pete is imperfect but he's trying to do
the right thing he's not denying that
and uh and he does have
you know he's uh
he's tireless and quite capable and fun
and anyway I I think it is it is very
well revealed by your your documentary
um but I wanted to come back to
something else just to kind of cap off
this piece of discussion
have you ever met somebody who's engaged
in radical honesty
you know what I'm talking about
can you can you can you talk about it
more because it's radical honesty is a
difficult
difficult concept for me I mean somebody
a lot of people try to be honest but but
they're they're kidding themselves so
it's hard for me to you know that's not
what I mean what I mean is somebody who
has reached the conclusion that
dishonesty is the problem and therefore
they are committed to saying exactly the
truth oh yeah oh at all times
yeah I have I've got to put a particular
one in in mind as well yeah complete
disaster yeah it's not good is it no no
it's it's terrible it's the worst
because what you really want is somebody
who is aligned in terms of values and
objectives
who you can trust to be as honest as
necessary for the situation right an
artificial commitment to the idea that
truth is so good that there's no amount
of it that's too much it's just
completely inconsistent with the animal
that we are to to be honest it was
probably a personality I would regard it
as personality floor of mine for many
years I I would I was that guy and there
was a kind of a kind of noble feeling I
got from
um dealing with the negative
consequences of speaking you know what
what I thought to be the truth and so
you people would recoil and friendships
would break down and things like that
and then I would stride ongoing I told
the truth I did my duty but um I guess
yeah yeah and More in more recent years
I kind of see that as a mistake or a
kind of
um I mean it's egotistical in itself in
some way because you are going you are
thinking that you are noble and better
and it's it's not it's not living in
concert with it's not living skillfully
maybe that's probably probably yeah
let's put it this way it leaves a lot of
value on the table it destroys some
value that doesn't need to be destroyed
and yes yes that that's probably it as
well I think that the progression
towards the things I wanted in life
um and it it's not a matter of lying to
get those things but it's a matter of
just you know biting your tongue and
sometimes
um well I mean I think you can you can
get to the problem with it with
reducto ad absurdum right the point is
there's lots of things that we do as a
function of our culture which
could be read is dishonest right you
close the door before using the toilet
right oh what are you hiding well
nobody's confused about what you're
hiding it's you're not really you're not
misleading anybody yeah it's just that
hey if we all close the door when we use
the toilet then we don't have to think
about somebody else using the toilet and
life is better and the point is you know
is it dishonest arguably but not in any
meaningful way right likewise
maybe I shouldn't share this oh no no I
won't share this but Pete's got a crass
way of saying that and I think I think
this is interesting because I think that
the the way that James Goes about his
business is too radical with it with
what he sees is honest and Pete Pete
often hit him up on that and said
said something very crass about what he
did this morning and he's like I'm not
about to tweet about that um I won't say
what it is but it's very funny anyway go
on well no that's that's perfect that's
exactly right and actually in in the
three subjects of your documentary you
have three very different uh thresholds
right Helen is in her own way
um a proper lady almost from another
time right
and
Peter is
a trickster who pushes limits for
Noble purpose
um
sometimes Beyond either his skill level
or anyone's skill level to pull it off
but nonetheless I have no doubt knowing
the man what his objective is and then
there's James who
I was thinking about it in looking at
I think it was part three of your your
documentary and uh
I was for some reason reminded of an
Immortal Technique song uh that a
student of mine pointed me to some years
ago where it's basically a description
of why he has been pushed too far and is
in a taking no prisoners mode the point
is I've seen too much I understand too
much and uh
I I'm active I'm I'm now a Warrior
against this yeah and I get that from
James and it uh on the one hand I know
exactly what he's reacting to and I
don't really think he's overreacting
on the other hand
is it the best use of the tools at his
disposal with respect to achieving the
values that he's targeting we have so
many conversations about this yeah yeah
a lot
um
but
anyway I guess so I wanted to compare
what you're doing in your films with
which I do not think is a disaster I
worry a little bit can the public handle
what you're showing them of something
historically important uh like The
Grieving studies hoax but
I also also I also kind of want to drag
down that that that kind of button-down
intellectual Country Club thing that
goes on because that's a facade I just I
kind of I want I like the dirty grubby
people that can do exactly what the guy
in the suit can do but doesn't need all
that crap and I know you do need it's
there's a lot of customary behaviors
within Academia that uh me you know is a
kind of far east and suburbs boy
entering that world I I just I don't
like it I just I I really I just I you
can see straight through and I do
understand the the you know the patentry
is part of the the actual
how would you say um
tradition and what you have to do and I
understand that there are some uh it's
not all customary and it's not all
social because the underlying
um thing that you guys are trying to do
within Academia is is very important and
should be respected and so on and so
forth but there's all these social
behaviors that I think that I think are
built on top of that that I I would like
to drag down because I want
anyone who can do the thing to do it and
for them to be accepted and so maybe
maybe that's that's part of it maybe
that's part of the protest I don't know
I mean you're talking my language and
because I am an academic I'm maybe in a
position to be more
aggressive about the perspective that I
think you and I share so I've had a uh a
way of saying this which is
um
the Country Club
is a place of
Mendes politeness right it's a
diabolical place in which schemes are
hatched by people right important
business schemes that create tremendous
Carnage but it's very you know please
and thank you and you know the pinky is
lifted when you drink your tea and all
this stuff and so I have no patience
whatsoever for
um the trappings of decency when they
surround something indecent and the
destruction of the academy
has left
um
a facade
of academic Behavior behind that I find
completely intolerable I find that very
interesting because I was about to I was
about to
pull back what I was saying before by
because I appreciate someone like a
Roger scrutin or there are a lot of
these
um english-born and and educated people
that are the thing
that we're talking about and there is
something authentic there and I'm I like
it and it kind of kind of even being
around it makes you want to stand up a
little more straight but um so yeah I
was I was trying to want I was trying to
separate what it is what it is that that
I recoil from the customary behaviors
that I'm looking at and something like
that which is actually beautiful you
know so I like that I like that you said
that because
um it puts it into perspective but
anyway go on well I mean
I think the thing is I'm all I want
there to be an academy right I would
love it to have beautiful buildings that
do make you want to stand up straight
and I would like it to employ people who
provoke you in the classroom to live up
to the standard that they set all of
that stuff sounds great to me
but I'm now allergic to it because I've
watched it be the only thing that
remains that something
has invaded that structure and it has
replaced the science with something that
looks superficially like science but
isn't right this looks like a
truth-seeking institution right it
speaks as if it's a truth-seeking
institution it is anything but it is a
truth obscuring institution and so you
know in this way
I'm you know I'm almost on on James page
here where what is taken over that very
important structure is unforgivable and
dangerous and so I'm all about
storming it from the outside and not
pretending that it's better than it is
and like you say I I love it when
somebody
um
proves that they can do the thing but
they don't look like the academy that
has now become a farce yeah right yeah I
love it when somebody does great science
or deeply inside I just love it when
people are doing the thing and and have
done the homework and when you're in the
presence of someone like that you don't
need
you know patches on your elbows and and
smoking pots and and all those weird
customary behaviors that we know you
know the rich mahogany and leather-bound
books you don't need any of that when
when someone's done the homework and you
know you know you know when you're
sitting in the presence of a person like
that
you do you do and and I wish I wish the
public understood how little the degrees
imply about whether or not somebody
should be listened to
right I say this as somebody who has a
PHD right and I I don't I'm in no way
embarrassed by what I did to earn my
degree but I also know that that degreed
is not in and of itself mean a damn
thing it means that you had the
persistence
to get the degree period doesn't mean
you know anything in fact it might mean
that you have spent
six eight ten years making yourself
Dumber that is something that frequently
happens
um
and I will say as a so I I don't know I
don't know how much you you and I have
probably talked about this but I was an
absolutely terrible student
um and not because I disrespected the
idea of being a good student I just
didn't have the skills for it
and when I became a professor one of the
weird things about Evergreen was that it
gave you because the founders of the
college literally threw out every single
normal structure that a college would
have right there were no departments
there were no Majors there weren't even
classes we had programs that could go on
for a full year in which a student took
one program at a time professors taught
one program at a time
these things were sometimes team taught
because students didn't have multiple
obligations you could take them into the
field I used to take them into the field
all the time with no particular purpose
just to get them to
let their guard down and talk to each
other and talk to me and think about
things deeply and stop thinking that
class stops at the end of the period or
whatever
um but anyway the point is in that
milieu I felt
I would have felt like a phony
if I had taught in a way that wouldn't
have worked for me as a student
right so I had to throw out all the
normal Professor stuff
and I had to start more or less from
scratch and figure out how can I teach
in a way that's effective at reaching
students and giving them something
valuable but is not a betrayal of my own
obstacles in school
right does not pretend that I'm
assigning them to do things that I would
have failed to do right
and one of the the punch line of this
story is that when I was in front of the
class I was aware that I was very much
the same person that I was at home I was
very much the same person that I was in
front of my kids
and that that I think
would surely be alarming to almost
anybody who believes in the academic
structure you walk into a classroom and
you find you know
Professor
goofing off cursing at some normal rate
right
um you know I used to do stuff like
um if I detected that a student was
trying to game the system by telling me
what I wanted to hear
I would latch on to what they were doing
and I would mislead them as to what I
wanted to hear and I would get them way
out on a limb right and then I would saw
it off behind them right because I don't
want you doing that you won't learn if
you if you please the professor if
that's your game it will not learn so
unless you unless
Sensei Behavior yeah yeah I mean I mean
I did I thought of it not as sensei
stuff I thought of it as
um
imagine that I was a tennis pro
right and I had a bunch of students who
didn't know how to play tennis
right I could spend all day at the board
diagramming and telling you about
the way tennis is played by people who
really understand where I could get on
the court and I could volley with you
and I could put the ball just out of
your reach so that you would get better
at knowing where the ball was going and
you would extend your reach right and so
it was like well
a do I know anything that's more useful
than just volleying with these people on
the topic that signed up to learn yeah
right so anyway
um
yeah the doing thing
is key it's way better than the
explaining thing in my opinion
um
and we might be in a time where the the
doers can get a signal boost now so
um I just I feel I feel like the the
academy might bleed out onto the
internet we'll see we'll see what
happens but um there seems to be a lot
of interesting things things going on on
the internet that are replacing the the
actual core function of what the the
academy did when you when you draw it
back to its first principles and so
um I think the research aspect of it
there's just not enough Finance
and and kind of you know the ability to
to do that outside of the
um the academy outside of think tanks
and things like that but
um it it it's it seems that
whatever function
the University was
was providing civilization
um there's opportunities to oh it's
first of all it's not really doing that
at some at some scale and then secondly
there's uh there's a lot more
opportunities to just do that thing
outside of those walls and the mahogany
and leather-bound books
I believe you're being
uh far more careful than you need to be
on this front and in fact
I would argue
covid perfectly reveals the problem
right it's not that the academy is
falling down on its obligation
it is actually actively making things
worse right and you could say that the
same thing for uh the official Halls of
medicine you could say the same thing
for the journalistic institutions you
could say the same thing for government
and that is a truly terrifying thing to
discover
you know I I'm I'm personally a little
annoyed because I feel I've been trying
to call attention
to the hazard of capture for 15 or 20
years and the problem is the whole idea
of capture is so boring
that it's impossible to get people to
pay attention to it enough to understand
how much danger it's putting them in and
so we are now decades late in addressing
the problem it's been a runaway problem
and it's it's fully captured almost
every institution maybe even every
institution above a tiny size
but
having discovered that and I believe how
how could you miss the across-the-board
failure that was coveted right every
single institution fell down on its
obligation to you and that not only left
you a drift it actively steered you into
self-harm right once you know that
then it's not exactly clear what you're
supposed to do
but it is clear that you need to figure
out what to substitute for that
institutional layer
right it's not hard to beat
an Institutional layer that is actively
steering you into self-harm and so what
you're pointing to is the internet being
a place where we are discovering what
else might do that job
uh I think it's quite right and and
we're doing it
um it's noisy
very noisy yeah yeah I think yeah things
will get worse before they get better
but you can only try and um I think
there's some very interesting stuff
happening
um and and opportunities for very
interesting stuff to be discovered and
done and so yeah why not be a digital
Pilgrim and try and build that world
so I know you've been down this road
fairly far digital uh pilgrims and uh
new Protestants I've heard you talk
about
what do you see as the route forward
what you say you see some hopeful signs
I guess I see a few as well
um but what do you see that makes you
hopeful and where do you think people
should be looking for uh a better
Direction
uh yeah it's hard to it's hard to say
I'm hopeful because I
I think things will get worse
but um I do also see a scattering of
opportunity all over the place where
we've got all kinds of Technology at our
fingertips we've got a lot of
interesting and and
um and motivated people that you can get
in contact really easily
um I mean something there's something
about the film if we want to bring it
back to that is it's a very it's a very
digital Story how strange that these
people could even
contact each other and and you know I'm
in Australia
um James South the southern part of
America Pete the the Pacific Northwest
Helen in the UK and and it all seemed to
work and we're collaborating and
um those things that those things
weren't possible before you know maybe
snail mail you could do something but it
just wouldn't happen at the rate and
scale at which it's happening now and so
I'm I'm having I'm utilizing the
technology at my finger tips to have all
these really interesting experiences and
so
I think it was horrible when when I was
in Victoria during the lockdown and that
was a very very horrible time
because I didn't
all my opportunities were
squashed into into nothing less than
nothing it was it was really really
horrible time but now
um
I'm overseas and meeting with people and
you know
making some money from the film which is
really cool
um I'm starting to be a little bit more
optimistic again but we've had we had
this conversation let's say even a year
ago maybe
um I would have been speaking very very
differently so I don't know what I can
say as to you know the the macro events
that are going to take place if if the
planet had a dashboard every one of the
lights would be flashing right now so as
I'm not super I'm not super confident
that we're not going to see some some
some major changes and some some really
horrific events but
if you
um boil that down to my first person
experience and and the opportunities at
my fingertips now I'm a little more
optimistic from from that level from the
ground level
well let me uh let me try to plant The
evolutionary lens at that a little bit
because I see the same thing and I think
your description every every single
light on the dashboard would be flashing
red based on all of the the failures the
simultaneous failures and incidentally
they're flashing red in a system where
we have
allowed the fail-safes to be unhooked
right we have a fragile system you know
it's one thing to have
you know a fire on a well-maintained
ship where everybody knows what they're
supposed to do and you can put it out
it's another thing to have had somebody
throw out the fire protocol so that the
extinguishers are
you know nobody's checked him in 10
years and you know the smoke detectors
have had their batteries removed or
whatever whatever the problem is and and
that's you know we have all the lights
flashing and a system that can't handle
one disaster let alone 10 simultaneous
ones
um but
the the analogy I would use that makes
me somewhat hopeful
is
we talk in evolution about the Adaptive
landscape in which opportunities are
represented as Peaks and obstacles to
moving to better opportunities are
represented as valleys
I won't go into the detail about why
it's so useful to evolutionarily think
this way it reveals certain things about
Evolution that are counter-intuitive
once you start thinking in these terms
but one thing I could say is
there's no guarantee that as you descend
into a valley
that you survive and you emerge to climb
a peak on the other side no guarantee at
all but
what is guaranteed is that it's very
unlikely for you to move to a
significantly higher Peak
without going through a value
right you can go into the valley and you
could your Telemetry can be off and you
can point yourself in a direction where
there's no peak that's a disaster you go
extinct
but
if you go into the valley
and you have some idea where that next
Peak is and you find yourself on the
foothill climbing it isn't as hard as it
looks
so
I guess what I would say is the fact
that things are very very dark
is not information one way or the other
about
what the future is going to look like
right it's necessary that we go through
a dark phase in order to be motivated to
climb that next Hill
growth spurts are painful it it could be
yeah a civilizational growth but that
we're going through but it's going to
hurt
well let's hope it is let's hope our
Telemetry is good but you know I mean
people can detect this in their own
personal lives as well right very dark
stuff actually precedes a radical
reorientation of your life that allows
you to do something new that maybe you
didn't see coming yeah and so in this
dark Valley
which maybe is the end of us
or maybe it's not it's the beginning of
some next phase we can't see
certain things are true and quite
positive
as you point out the modern tech
facilitates collaboration between people
who wouldn't have found each other even
if they had the obstacle to
collaborating would have been so great
even 20 years ago
that it wouldn't have happened
but in this era
we have tools that if we can keep them
from being commandeered by whatever the
authoritarian monster is
we can utilize and the
I mean the beautiful thing about the era
is that the force that wants above all
else to prevent meaningful change which
I call Goliath but you can use your own
term
that Force
has simultaneously demonized
all the best people
right it has shoved them out of normal
trajectories it has purged them from the
institutions right and so to my way of
thinking
Goliath has created a Dream Team on the
outside of the institutional lair
right and let's put it this way I don't
know where we are in history
but I sure as hell know what team I'm on
and you just had a very interesting uh
I've been reading a bit of this elite
theory that all the post-liberals are
kind of circulating in those
post-liberal circles and it's um you've
just you've just created your own Brett
Weinstein a high version of this elite
theory where uh there's not a there's
not an adequate circulation of Elites
and
um they've got the problem now that that
uh the elites a new Elite
network is growing outside of the uh the
the the kind of established order and um
I I there's a lot to it there's a lot to
it it's a very compelling argument and
it maps on to how power is working right
now
um I do worry that that's that's the
story that animates me you know you
you're we're on a podcast called The
Dark Horse and there you go you know the
the The Big Short is one of my favorite
films
if someone is going if someone's going
to like that as an animating narrative
it's probably you and I but I think that
I think that it does map on to
um to a lot of real world observations I
like to observe things and then come and
then theorize afterwards and I think
um anyway that's that's the that's the
one I think I think I'm with you all
right well I wanna I wanna fix one thing
though uh you said Elite and my blood
pressure went up and not in a good way
right
and I want to borrow a little uh piece
of Kit from the many interesting Special
Forces folks who uh are circulating in
these intellectual
Realms right
uh this is something Heather pointed me
to
um
not Elite
all right it's not the elite forces
special
the two things are different Elite is an
eye rolling
uh category and one I I do not aspire to
join I am not interested in hearing what
they have to
says of the elite I'm interested in you
know the special forces in this case
they will be special forces that are not
inherently military but nonetheless it
is time for this question someone said
something very very not PC but when they
watched the film they said man it's like
the Avengers
[Laughter]
these superheroes who are very very
strange and uh yeah yeah they are but I
mean look at the look The the thing is
there is something and I I can't swear
that I've actually seen The Avengers or
could even you know I haven't but I I
you know I get it the superheroes it
saves the world yeah yeah right and I
there is something to be said for the
idea that look I use the term Goliath
for the force that opposes meaningful
change right
the prime directive of Goliath is there
shall be no meaningful change there can
be plenty of change but anything that
meaningfully adjusts the flow of
well-being and control is forbidden
um
but that thing is not a dude right in
biblical times there probably was a
giant called Goliath he was probably a
pituitary tumor victim
and a a brutal dick and uh it wasn't uh
David who actually failed him that was
uh you know biblical stagecraft I
believe the guy who actually failed him
was El Hanan but nonetheless
there was a time when there was a
Goliath
and there was an El Hanan and the story
unfolded as it was everything has been
scaled up when you think about the
number of people who would have been on
Earth at that time
and the number of people who are on
Earth today right were orders of
magnitude away and
the point is Goliath isn't a dude
anymore Goliath is a composite between
various conspiring cabals and
institutions and emergent properties
that uh facilitate what goliath does and
you know David slash El Hanan isn't
going to be a person either it's going
to be a collective of people with very
different skill sets who realize that
our well-being our persistence even is
dependent on getting control of
the structures that allow us to uh to
run the planet and you know to write the
ship
um so the problem the problem with those
people is they're they're usually so
um
contrarian's not the word but they're
usually very very difficult
to work with and and
um getting them to collaborate on
anything at scale is is near impossible
I think that's a that's a major problem
for this this David construct that
you're you're putting together here well
here's the thing
um when I was thinking about what to
call the podcast Dark Horse was the
right term but second in line was
something like
uh the lone wolf pack
my move pack that's interesting yeah so
anyway I see the problem yeah these
people are not well built for
partnership in some ways which is a
problem and I think there's a second
problem which is that all of us
have grown up we've gone through our
development in
a market
and a market teaches very bad lessons
about
partnership because effectively you
Source all kinds of things on the open
market that
become shallow when you do
right if
you know the the job once done by a
trusted
friend or a clergy member is now done by
a psychologist you pay by the hour
that's interesting yeah yeah that is
interesting
that's
the it's almost it's almost Marxist
really isn't it the the market as the
atomizing
um process is that that yeah I haven't
really considered it that way but yeah
that that is what happens right yeah it
is what happens and it teaches us very
bad lessons so you know I worry when I
hear
um the modern special analytical forces
considering their
how to organize I worry
that people aren't even aware that they
have you know they may be very good at
certain things but that there's a skill
set in which their novices that actually
they need to become much better at if
they are to accomplish the job and it
has to do with deep human Partnerships
of the kind but maybe now we only see on
battlefields
yeah
yeah that's interesting it's definitely
some food for thought there yeah for
sure
well are there other topics that you
would like to cover before we close this
out
I don't think so
um
yeah let's do it again sometime I always
enjoy talking to you yeah I always enjoy
talking with you as well you're never in
the same place you seem to move around a
lot which we Nomad it's it's I don't
feel comfortable in Australia anymore so
I'm trying I'm trying trying to be
somewhere else but my Visa keeps
disappearing and so I'm always always at
a new place I'm on the move all right
well uh okay Mike Nana it has been a
real pleasure and we have gone places I
did not foresee
uh which is always great
your current project is the reformers a
four-part series which people can find
on your sub stack yeah yeah Michael
Naina substack.com Michael Naina sostek
and Naina is n-a-y-n-a
right that's it
um great uh anything else you want to
point people towards Twitter handle
um
yeah just type in Michael neener or Mike
Naina and then you'll see it all right
awesome
um well thank you so much for joining me
and I look forward to seeing your next
project into talking to you about what
it looks further on through the Adaptive
Valley
thanks for having me yeah all right be
well everyone
[Music]
foreign